dying stars can go out
with a bang an enormous explosion called
a supernova
these cosmic pyrotechnics shoot chemical
elements and energetic particles out
into space
and the explosion can release more
energy than the sun will
over its entire life but scientists
don't fully understand the
extreme physics of supernova explosions
that's because there's nothing like them
on earth or
is there
[Music]
supernovas are fascinating they are not
just distant explosions they are the
source of
elements like the iron in our blood and
the calcium in our bones
but they're really far away so there's
no hopping on a spacecraft to check one
out
in our galaxy supernovas only happen a
few times a century
so spotting one nearby with the
telescope is a waiting game
so scientists are using laboratory
explosions to bring the physics of a
supernova
down to earth here's what we do know
when a really big star gets old it
eventually runs out of fuel
its core collapses and rebounds that
triggers a wave of high density and
pressure that plows outward through the
star
when this wave reaches the surface the
star explodes
igniting a light show that could
outshine its entire home
galaxy a mix of electrically charged
particles or plasma
blasts into space at about 10 000
kilometers per second
the explosion leaves behind a remnant an
expanding bubble of gas and plasma
within the remnant itself a shock wave
forms and
flings out charged particles to energies
that outdo
even the biggest particle accelerators
on earth
and that remnant it can stick around for
hundreds of thousands of years
it's impossible to fully replicate the
physics of a supernova in the laboratory
for one thing a real supernova would
blow up everything in sight
but the same physics governs how charged
particles flow
in giant supernovas and in lab made
blasts that are shrunk down to a
manageable size
scientists also focus on one bit of the
physics at a time
they might try to reproduce the
supernova remnants shockwave for example
but not all the other complicated
physics that goes on during the
explosion
if you want to understand supernovas you
might as well start bic
the national ignition facility at
lawrence livermore national laboratory
in california
has 192 laser beams that can momentarily
unload more power than the entire united
states uses
in a given instant one team of
physicists
is using these lasers to study shock
waves in supernova remnants
this kind of shock wave shows up when
the blasts plasma
collides with other plasma that's
already hanging out in interstellar
space
there electric and magnetic fields grow
stronger
these electromagnetic fields not only
help form the shock wave
but they also ping-pong charge particles
back and forth across it
each time the particles cross they speed
up eventually reaching extreme energies
but the details of how the magnetic
fields form and
how the particles are accelerated have
been a mystery
scientists use lasers like those at the
national ignition facility to produce
colliding bursts of plasma
revealing how magnetic fields form
within
in a recent experiment scientists also
reproduce a supernova remnant
shock wave showing for the first time
how particles are accelerated
if you don't happen to have 192 laser
beams at your disposal
good old-fashioned explosives can also
do the trick
researchers at georgia tech are focused
on recreating the early moments of a
supernova
let's rewind before stars go supernova
they are layered like an onion
with heavier elements like iron in the
center and lighter elements like
hydrogen on the outside
when the pressure wave inside the star
rams through the onion layers
elements from the stars innards are
ejected
to understand how those layers behave in
the early moments of a supernova
the georgia tech team came up with a
dynamite strategy
build a pizza slice-shaped blast chamber
to mimic a wedge of a star
fill it with two layers of gas to mimic
the onion structure
and add a powerful explosive to capture
the blast's aftermath the researchers
illuminate the gas with laser light
and they let her rip as the resulting
blast wave plows through
the gas layers form bubbles spikes and
mushroom shaped tendrils
and some material flies outward the
experiments show that these kinds of
explosions
can mimic a supernova and they might
help researchers better understand
how elements are ejected from within a
star and
better understanding these early stages
of a supernova
could help researchers explain the
complex structures that are seen later
in supernova remnants
supernovas are some of the most extreme
environments in the cosmos by studying
them we are exploring uncharted realms
of physics bringing supernovas down to
earth with experiments could
help us understand other cosmic
mysteries like how magnetic fields form
in
other realms of the universe
while the bang might spell the end of a
star it's just the beginning
the elements it releases go out to
enrich the cosmos
the shock wave formed in the supernova
remnant could collapse
clouds of gas helping to form new stars
and energetic particles accelerated by
that shock wave
will streak across the sky perhaps one
day
crash landing on earth a supernova is
the culmination of a star's life
but it's the start of countless other
stories
you